what's up you guys welcome back to
flickers of fear and we're still in
march so we're still doing monster march
where we're talking about all kinds of
monster movies now this movie right here
was
another one that kind of seemed to go
under my radar and i didn't realize
until i started researching it
that since it came out in 1998 it's
really kind of developed a rather large
cult following
um and i actually didn't realize this
until i noticed that two of my very
favorite movie review youtubers ryan
hollinger and oliver harper had both
separately done a standalone episode on
this movie and i was kind of like well
maybe this is a good time to uh you know
to see that because
i feel like it was one that i sort of
vaguely remember hearing about it when
it came out
but when it came out um you know i'll
get into that in a bit it really didn't
do
all that well and it sort of got
forgotten about so i kind of feel like
it's one of those ones that appreciation
for it has grown a lot over the years so
the movie i'm talking about is deep
rising from 1998.
now this was actually directed by steven
summers
who would go on to do some massive hits
uh the mummy not the tom cruise one the
brendan fraser one and the mummy returns
uh he did van helsing which i wasn't a
big fan of but okay uh but yeah so he
did actually go on to helm some really
large uh you know big hollywood tentpole
type movies in the uh early 2000s
and i kind of feel like at first when
this movie was first conceived
i feel like the studio behind it which
is actually disney through another one
of their uh you know other studios that
they that they owned
i kind of feel like they were
initially thinking this was going to be
kind of like a big
uh vehicle for harrison ford because he
was actually supposed to play the main
character now at the time that this was
you know being kind of knocked about
like they were going to make it steven
summers his original the original
screenplay was actually called tentacle
and at the point when they were talking
about making it there really weren't any
kind of big monster like old-school
b-movie big monster type of movies so
they thought maybe this was probably
like a good bet and if they could get
like a big star like harrison ford to be
in it then maybe they could really cash
in with the [ __ ]
but as it happened because of various
delays and whatnot
uh this ended up coming out
much later than it was initially
intended to uh not only was it
released in the quote-unquote dump month
of january where everyone's just kind of
like not really seeing all that movies
and map that many movies and that's
usually where studios not so much
nowadays i feel like but for a long time
that's kind of where studios would dump
a lot of their movies that they thought
weren't going to do all that well
and they would just put them out then
but by the time this came out there had
already been some other monster movies
from other studios like mimic and the
relic and anaconda and stuff like that
so you know so this one didn't really
look all that original by comparison
even though i as far as i know it was
kind of the first one that was supposed
to be made but you know because various
things intervened it ended up ended up
coming out later than uh than it should
have and i will note too that it might
have suffered because
at this point uh titanic was out
and titanic pretty much [ __ ] on every
single other [ __ ] movie because
titanic if you weren't around uh in the
late 1990s when titanic came out
it was such a huge cultural juggernaut
that i mean people were going to the
theater to see it like multiple times
so any other movie that came out in
proximity to and it was number one at
the box office for like four months or
like some ridiculously long time so
people were going to see it multiple
times and it was like pretty much
crushing like every other movie that
came out um you know in the months of
its release so it might have this movie
might have suffered from that a little
bit as well
now as i said initially it was supposed
to have harrison ford in it supposed to
be like you know but there's like really
good people working on this rob boutin
who obviously did the thing among many
other things
did the special effects work on it
although we'll get into that in a minute
too
but so this actually did have big people
working on it but when harrison ford
turned the movie down
disney kind of shunted this off to one
of their
i don't know if you want to call it
their one of their lesser studios but at
this point in time in 1998 disney had i
believe four other studios uh that
weren't called disney under their uh you
know their umbrella now two of them kind
of operated on their own but then they
had these two uh touchstone which was
kind of their more
independent uh you know in indie movie
like more oscar bait kind of high-end
type of studio and then they had
hollywood pictures which was kind of
more their b picture kind of thing but
both of those they had them disney had
them so that they could release more
adult oriented pictures you know and
then they could keep the disney brand
just for kid stuff or family stuff so
this kind of got shunted down to
hollywood uh pictures
and uh the budget was cut uh when
harrison ford couldn't come in to be in
it and i believe this movie ended up
costing 45 million dollars uh
unfortunately it made less than 12
million back at the box office for some
of the reasons that i've already gone
into uh so it was uh quite a big failure
also a very big critical failure
strangely cisco and ebert they uh very
famously hated this movie which i don't
really get i mean this is not a super
this is actually a really fun
movie and i don't really get why they
hated it so much i mean there was a lot
shittier movies that came out in 1998
that's for goddamn sure
but i don't know why they hated it so
much but they did actually put it on
their most hated list and a lot of
critics while they didn't hate it were
just kind of like oh it's very
derivative it's basically like
you know alien on a boat which
sure uh yeah it is that but honestly
alien was such
a massive i mean it's such a masterpiece
that yeah it's and i don't want to say
like every movie that's like alien oh
well it's not good because it's just
like alien as i said horror as a genre
monster movies there's really not a lot
of
you know play there if you want to stay
within that genre so you're going to see
tropes repeating and that absolutely
does not bother me at all as long as
you're not ripping something off
completely as long as you have some new
kind of angle that you're coming at it
from then i'm not bothered if it's kind
of like and you know one uh example that
me and tom have talked about a lot was
the movie underwater which came out a
couple years back and you know people
said oh it's alien but like under like
in an underwater
drilling station or whatever and i'm
like yeah but it was still like a really
good movie like i found it really
entertaining and it's the same with this
one this is just like a really fun
monster movie and honestly it's not just
a monster movie because for almost the
first
not quite the first half but it's almost
kind of like a crime like a heist movie
and then like with little hints that
there's like some monster action like
coming up on the horizon and then it
goes full-on gory monster movie now i
think the producers too uh really were
pushing to
knock out some of the gore and make this
more of a pg-13 but uh to their credit
like the director and everything like
that we're just like absolutely not
we're keeping this as an r rating and uh
indeed this is like quite gory now the
special effects in it as i said roboteen
worked on it and i believe some of the
effects are practical
but i don't know it's kind of hard to
tell how much of the practical effects
still ended up on the fi on the you know
final cut of the movie because
the monster in this is very very
obviously cgi
and it's really not very good cgi now
it's good cgi for the time because like
i said they did spend a lot of money on
this movie it's not like cheap or
anything like that but
even good cgi from 1998 uh still looks
pretty shitty like by today's standards
uh particularly when the monster you
know like eats somebody or something
like that and it's just like shaking
around this rubbery looking you know
what i mean and it's just the monster is
just like too shiny and [ __ ] like that
but it's like a minor quibble as i said
it had good special effects for the time
it's not the movie's fault that uh that
cgi just really hasn't aged that well
and honestly in the late 90s they were
using cgi for every [ __ ] thing and uh
that's why i kind of i'm a big advocate
especially if you're doing gore effects
monster effects stuff like that where
possible i think it's better to use as
much practical effects as you can um
because it won't age whereas cgi
absolutely does and you know even a
couple years from now cgi from movies
now is not going to look as good as it
will later so practical effects always
better especially in horror movies
so what we have in this movie uh since
they couldn't get harrison ford
uh they actually got treat williams a
character actor who's been in 50
bajillion things uh so he's kind of
playing i guess i don't know this movie
would have been very very different i
think with han solo in the lead i kind
of feel like he might have been too
serious i think they wanted him because
the main character played by treat
williams in this is sort of like a han
solo type um you know what i mean he's
sort of like morally gray type of type
of dude and he's kind of a little bit of
a mercenary even though he's uh
good-hearted so i kind of feel like they
were going for sort of like a han solo
thing but honestly i think by the time
1998 had rolled around i think harrison
ford
had shed a lot of that persona uh
because he was you know playing more
kind of like
executive type roles or you know like
i'm a secret serge service agent or like
action type roles so i'm not sure i
don't know i just kind of maybe i'm
totally off base on that but i was
thinking about this earlier like what
would this movie have been like with han
with han solo in it with with the
harrison ford in it as he was in 1998
i'm not sure it would have been quite as
fun because the thing that's cool about
this movie
is that everybody looks like they're
having a really good time i mean they
know this is just like a big fun
monster movie and no one's taking it all
that seriously but on the other hand
it's not like a straight up comedy
either but everybody just really does
look like they're having a good time and
i'm really not sure if you would have
got the same vibe with harrison ford in
it
so treat william is the main character
uh famke janssen is also in this even
though i think they wanted claire for
lonnie uh originally but she uh was only
on the set for a few days and didn't get
along with the director so she quit uh
famke janska janssen uh they actually
weren't gonna put her in the movie
because she had just been in goldeneye
and they thought that she was two they
wanted people that were maybe more
character actors or weren't as well
known but they did end up putting her in
it she actually plays kind of like a
jewel thief who's on this cruise ship uh
and there's also a bunch of other
anthony uh healed held however you
pronounced his last name uh who probably
most famously was dr chilton in silence
and lambs the first one from 1991
and uh there's like this movie actually
has a massive massive cast uh which is
good you want a lot of cannon fodder
when you're when you're making a monster
movie so the monster has plenty of
people to snack on
so uh what we have at the beginning as i
said
this movie for the first
i want to say 20 30 minutes maybe longer
um there is some hint of like monster
action and they do give you like a
little title card at the beginning that
says something about you know way down
deep there's these like [ __ ] animals
like we don't know what the [ __ ] is down
there basically that kind of message uh
so you know that there's gonna be and
there's like a you know like a shot of
something swimming through
some underwater [ __ ] like with a growly
kind of noise so you know that there's
gonna be a monster coming into play at
some point but for a while uh they do
kind of set up essentially like a heist
sort of uh situation
so there's this crew of like mercenaries
uh one of which is tree williams and
then he has like this other guy joey who
is played by the great uh kevin j
o'connor who is actually in a lot of uh
of this guy's movies and uh he's the
best i mean he's kind of like the comic
relief but
not in an obnoxious way and apparently
he did a lot of um ad-libs in this as
well so yeah he's great he's super funny
uh so he's kind of like the mechanic on
the boat uh you know treat williams
plays finnegan who's the captain and
then there's also layla who is another
member of the crew and is also joey's
girlfriend
now uh so these are like i said
mercenaries they have a thing where it's
just like hey if you're paying us money
we don't give a [ __ ] what you're doing
we're just you know if you need a boat
we'll take you someplace we're not going
to ask any questions
uh so they have this uh gang on their
boat
who
again paid them to take them someplace
but they didn't really ask like uh what
was going on
turns out that this uh other gang that
they're driving around
on this boat
uh their mission is they're going to go
and attack this new
cruise ship called the argonautica which
is kind of like this big luxury
uh you know state-of-the-art cruise ship
with you know hundreds thousands of
people on it
and what they're gonna do is they're
going to get on the ship they're going
to rob everybody like the vaults and
everything like that and then they're
going to torpedo the ship and sink it
and you know probably kill everybody
so there's that uh so you get a little
bit of [ __ ] going on like on the cruise
ship which is run by uh anthony heald's
character simon canton who is kind of
this big you know sort of robber baron
type character and he's like oh my my
dream was to make the most luxurious
expensive
uh cruise ship in the world and thank
you all you guys for you know making my
dream come true and blah blah so there's
that kind of thing
mostly though you're following the
mercenaries and the robber gang the gang
of robbers that's on this uh you know
smaller boat now on the cruise ship
there's also fanca jansen's character
whose name is trillian and she's kind of
like this international jewel thief spy
kind of thing so she's sort of trying to
rob the [ __ ] too she's not trying to
kill anybody she's just trying to get
into the vault and uh you know get all
the jewels and money and whatever the
hell is in there so uh the movie takes a
while like setting up this dynamic
and uh the mercenaries on the ship
are kind of like slowly they discover
in you know in the ship's hold they're
like what the there's all these like
torpedoes in there it's like that's
probably not good and so they're trying
to ask again what the [ __ ] are we doing
like why do you have these and uh then
obviously the gangs sort of like pull
guns on everybody and they're like hey
you know you just do what we tell you
and we paid you and blah blah blah so
something hits the cruise ship from
underneath you don't really see what it
is uh but you're led to believe you know
it's a monster movie it's a sea monster
so it hits the cruise ship from
underneath the ship starts to sink
and one of the uh speed boats or
lifeboat or something like that is
jarred loose from the cruise ship and
the smaller boat
uh hits
the hits that
so now the mercenaries and the robber
gang are you know they are forced to
kind of like go over and get on the
cruise ship and they're like well that's
okay that's where we were going anyway
so they get on there but by the time
they get on the cruise ship uh because
you know a little bit of time passes
uh they don't find anybody on board like
they get on board and everything's kind
of like [ __ ] up obviously because the
sea monster hit it from underneath and
uh you know so there's [ __ ] everywhere
and then they come up and there's kind
of nobody's there and there's like blood
everywhere and so there's kind of like
huh well this is
interesting like where did everybody go
like did they all jump overboard or this
is like really weird uh so they're kind
of weirded out but then they're like
well it makes our job easier whatever so
we're just gonna like find the ball and
get [ __ ] and get the [ __ ] out of here uh
but obviously that is not how it goes so
once kind of that gets established and
they all get on the cruise ship and
they're trying to figure out where the
[ __ ] everybody on the cruise ship went
to they're trying to like go through
this massive ship and like find the
vault and uh you know
it will surprise no one that the monster
starts coming after them now they also
find famke janssen who because she was
caught trying to get into the vault uh
the ship's brig wasn't done yet so they
threw her in this um
like a food storage pantry type thing
where they could lock her in so she
actually avoided because she was locked
up she avoided getting uh eaten by the
monsters and or knocked overboard so she
kind of like joins up with them as well
as they try to make their way out the
boat and like i said the cruise ship is
kind of sinking too because it's damaged
so they're trying to make their way uh
you know get the money and get the hell
out before the monster gets and they
don't realize what it is at first and
they actually don't show the monster for
quite a long time like they'll show
like a little bit of splash over there
or they'll show like it's really good
like the way they build the tension up i
really really like the way that they
established the situation like the
robbers and the crew
getting on or the mercenaries like
getting on the ship and everyone being
gone and them like trying to figure out
what the hell happened like where
everybody went to
because this ship had like hundreds of
thousands of people on it and now all
that's there is just like people's stuff
and then like some blood and stuff so so
i really like that that set up and i
really like that it took a while like
for the monster to kind of like appear
so the monster when you finally see it
like i said it's a cool design um it's
just that you know cgi in 1998 wasn't
really all that good so you can
obviously tell uh you know it looks like
a video game type of thing but it's not
i think initially because it was
initially called tentacle and because
the first glimpses of it you see are
kind of like looks sort of like squid or
octopus tentacles so i was kind of
thinking that it was sort of like a
squid or an octopus which it is
but it's also
it's actually based on a real
c worm but
much much much bigger because i think
like the actual worm that they based it
on is only like this big you know what i
mean it's like pretty small like only a
couple of inches whereas this one is
like [ __ ] giant and it has all of
these tentacles that
from what i could determine seemed like
they all moved independently and each
had kind of like little mouths either
that or there was a whole bunch of them
you know what i'm saying and i wasn't
clear over whether this was one organism
or whether it was just like a [ __ ] ton
because when they get to the end and
they find like the big boss you know
what i mean and it's this really big
massive and it kind of looks like an
octopus like it has a big roundy kind of
head but it also kind of looks like a
weird like seaworm type thing with like
the mouth and everything but then all of
its other tentacles also have
kind of like mouths and grabby and they
can kind of like go and like follow
everybody so i will say too that so even
though the monster the monster design is
like really cool like i said the cgi
looks crappy but you know what are you
gonna do it's the 90s uh that's just
that's just what it looked like back
then sorry but other than that like a
lot of the practical gore like
especially the one place the one time
where they find uh the quote unquote
feeding ground because one of the things
this monster does and i think this was
like a really nice touch because this is
like really horrific if you think about
it they said okay well
this monster doesn't necessarily like
eat you
what it wants to do is it will kind of
like take you in one of its little
tentacles and then it will like drink
you like a capri sun
and then like you know what i mean so
you could actually technically and this
does happen like in the movie a time or
two
that you're still like alive
while this thing is like sucking out all
your body fluids and then it'll like
take you in and then it like spits out
your skeletal remains so they find like
at some point this massive uh you know
this this kind of like massive space
like in the ship that the monster has
been using for a feeding ground and
there's just like these goopy like red
skeletons like everywhere and it looks
really cool uh but yeah i really like
that shot too and there's just really uh
one of the most famous sequences from
this too was there's this one guy named
billy who was one of the gang like one
of the robber gang with the missiles
and he gets
taken into one of the tentacles or
whatever of the monster and then later
he kind of gets spit out and he's kind
of still alive but he's sort of like
half digested looking and it looks
really even though it's cgi but some of
it's practical too it's like practical
looks like with um with some cgi like
laid over it but it actually does look
pretty good so i really did like that uh
effect as well but yeah so i mean to be
honest i can see why this got
uh you know why this got a cult
following i don't understand why
critics didn't love it back you know
yeah it's derivative other monster
movies but
like i said there's only so much you can
do within the monster movie parameters
and
you know so i think that that kind of
like does the movie a disservice by just
saying oh it's like alien but in a
different environment i'm like yeah
you're talking about like 99 of all
monster movies so what's your problem i
don't really know but i didn't really
get the hate for it because this is
actually just a fun
b-movie monster movie and it's actually
like for a b movie it's actually like
pretty big budget like i said 45 million
dollars even the late 90s that was
you know nothing really to sneeze at for
a movie of this type
um and they had like really good people
working on it like i said like rob
boutin and stuff and uh you know i think
he didn't jerry goldsmith didn't he do
the i want to say jerry goldsmith did
the score which like i said that's
pretty prestigious as well so this
wasn't just like a throwaway
movie i think maybe what happened was
that
because of the delays in release you
know and the fact that some other
monster movies that were similar had
come out subsequently came up before it
even though it was supposed to come out
before them and the fact that titanic
was out and was just kind of like
crushing everybody under its feet like
godzilla and you know it's titanic was
also set on a boat or on a cruise ship
and so maybe people like oh another
cruise ship thing no thanks you know
what i mean i've already seen titanic
and a million times so maybe it was that
um so i do kind of feel like maybe the
timing of the release
didn't help it either
and maybe so maybe people were kind of
like over movies on boats or over
monster movies by that point because as
i said two or three other monster movies
had come out right before it so maybe it
looked like it was a rip-off even though
it really wasn't so you know i think a
lot of things conspired to
make sure this movie didn't do all that
well but i am happy to report that even
though they didn't make any money on it
at the time at least uh the director
stephen summers uh you know his career
wasn't ruined happily and he actually
did go on to do some good films like the
brandon fraser mummy ones which are
actually a lot of fun and actually if
you like those you'll probably really
dig this too because the tone of the the
tone of this is very similar uh as i
said it's not comedic but it does have a
lot of funny stuff in it like the
character of joey in particular uh
because he did a lot of ad-libs and
stuff is was my favorite character
easily uh in the movie i love that actor
anyway and uh so he's just like this
great like sardonic character and uh so
i really so i really like like all the
character interactions in it everyone's
just very kind of like funny
and but it's not like comedic and it's
still
really gory
you know there's still like a lot of
really horrific [ __ ] happening in it so
it kind of has something for everybody
uh you know it's like i said it's just a
lot of fun just a fun expensive
b movie that doesn't take itself too
seriously but
is still like a blast to watch
so if you want to watch it actually at
the moment i watched it on 2b for free
you might also i think you can also
watch it on amazon prime for free
although i'm not entirely sure about
that but i watched it on toby and it's
for sure on there and it is absolutely
worth watching i'm not generally a big
fan of and i think i've mentioned this
before i'm not generally a big fan of
horror movies from about the mid 90s
like post scream to like the mid 2000s
because i feel like there was
like i said a lot of it was just kind of
like cgi fests or they were like shitty
remakes or they were kind of like
slasher reboots with
you know kind of
these bland pretty looking people
getting chopped up and a lot of them
were just kind of like samey
but uh this one was actually like really
really good for the time i had a really
good time watching this one really good
monster movie monster was even though
the cgi is kind of uh crappy it really
is a good monster design and a good
lore behind the monster because it's
like based on a real animal but they
obviously like made it like way way
bigger so and i liked the whole aspect
about them like drinking people because
i thought that was like and then
spitting out the skeleton you know i
thought that was like really cool
because if you think about that that's
like
pretty horrifying and anything set in
the deep ocean like with big monsters
coming from the deep ocean that's
automatically going to be like scarier
to me because [ __ ] that i mean [ __ ] the
ocean like you don't know what the [ __ ]
is down there there could actually be
something like that down there we
wouldn't even know which is even more
terrifying to think about but yeah
seriously go over to tubey and watch
deep rising if you haven't seen it it's
a lot of fun and i kind of feel like i'm
glad that now it had like a nice 20th
anniversary uh release a couple years
back
with a really nice cover looks very love
crafty and and uh so i thought that was
kind of cool so it's cool that like uh
you know it's got some appreciation now
but if you have seen it or if you
haven't seen it let me know uh what you
thought about it in the comments and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear continuing on with monster march
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye